[موسيقى]
نحن نتمتع بتبادل
أساليبنا التكتيكية مرة أخرى الإجراءات
بالإضافة إلى فرصة العمل مع
بعضنا البعض
[موسيقى]
من تخطيط
وتوليد التمرين لم يتغير ، لكن
بالتأكيد
إذا كنت تسميها الغلاف  حولها ، ربما يكون
نوع البيئة العسكرية السياسية
المحيطة بها قد تغيرت
قليلاً بالتأكيد
نعم تعمل السفن الروسية في البلطيق
مثل سفن حربية الناتو أو سفن جميع
الدول الأعضاء
والدول المجاورة
لبحر البلطيق
والسفن الحربية الروسية والسفن المدنية
هي  شائع جدًا
أه نحن هنا لتقوية العضلات
أه نحن هنا لتقوية الروح
أه نحن هنا لتقوية العقل
أه وحقيقة وحقيقة في الجهد
الرئيسي لإعلام الناس في أوروبا
السماح للعائلات في المجتمعات بمعرفة
أنهم  ليس لديك ما يدعو للقلق
لأنه إذا حاول أي شخص أن يأتي إلى
هنا ويقدم الكراهية والسخط
لأهل الناتو ،
فأنت